madame
Martin il y a un petit problème je crois
à savoir que vous en tant que président
de la commission des lois vous devez
interrompre cette commission vous devez
interrompre cette commission y compris
sur des aspects démocratiques
républicains je vais évidemment pas
parler avec vous de courtoisie et donc à
partir de là pour que nous puissions
pour que nous puissions aller dans
l'hémicycle suivre un projet de loi qui
dépend
une proposition de loi de/ cro c'est
presque encore pire parce que c'est une
proposition qui émane d'un certain
nombre d'entre nous les députés donc il
faut lever
immédiatement la commission des lois
pour que nous puissions aller dans
leshémicycle et pouvoir suivre les
débats autour du sujet qui concerne les
commissaires aux lois donc je pense que
vous devez prendre cette décision toute
façon si vous la prenez pas je vous
garantis on va faire tout scrutin public
tout tout absolument tout il y a auun
problème avec
çaadame alors madame madame madame
Martin et les membres de la commission
en réalité ici ici comme ailleurs il y a
un principe Nemo auditure nul ne peut se
prévaloir de ses propres turpitudes on
aurait dû suspendre effectivement à
21h30 à 21h30 pour examiner vos
propositions vous avez retiré votre
proposition précédente avant le terme de
cette proposition vous avez donc
organisé laavenue en séance il y a en ce
moment
pasous on est à ce moment en séance la
discussion générale sur la proposition
de Madame obono on est tout à l'heure
les amendements pour les amendements il
y aura tout le monde mais ça ça suffit
monsieur bernalissis vous enfin vous
vous comportez comme un enfant ça n'est
pas acceptable dans la Commission et
donc nous allons poursuivre nos travaux
je mets au voix l'amendement de madame
yousoufa qui vote pour pas de problème
qui vote contre il est rejeté amendement
278 Monsieur
G ça suffit non il est tombé monsieur
gilet votre amendement je suis désolé
l'amendement suivant le
765 il est tombé
également je vais le défendre monsieur
le Président ça suffit le 765 est tombé
non non non ben non je le défends 76
mais attendez président président
j'étais en train de le défendre le 765
il est tombé à cause de l'amendement
d'un amendement précédent ça suffit
monsieur Bern vous arrêtez de faire
l'enfantapricieux faire capricieux ça
suffit il est il est tombé
le ça
suffit ça suffit ça
suffit le 767 qui le défend pour la
France
insoumise on va r 767 il est pas défendu
vous devez lever cette séance quand même
mais quand
même tu veux parler madame mchou oui
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
vous écoutez vous écoutez la
vice-présidente s'il vous plaît merci
Monsieur bernalicis on arrête on arrête
par enfant on écoute je voudrais
simplement témoigner d'une chose si vous
me le permettez j'ai été présente en
conférence des présidents quand la
question de la surcharge de travail de
la commission des lois a été évoquée et
le président H a pris la parole pour
dire qu'un certain nombre de textes
venaient à l'examen qu'un trop grand
nombre de textes venaient à l'examen et
il a demandé que la soit revu pour
permettre que nous participions
justement au travaux en commission et au
travaux en séance publique la demande a
été s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît donc
le président de la Commission a fait
état de ces difficultés du fait que nous
ne pouvons pas nous dédoubler
effectivement les présidents les
présidents des groupes politiques
étaient présents aucun aucun ne s'est
exprimé sur le sujet votre présidente de
groupe n'a pas pris la parole pour non
mais je vous le dis écoutez je fais état
de faits objectifs je déplore la même
chose bon la décision a été prise de
maintenir l'agenda il faudra soulever ce
point en conférence des présidents et en
faire part à la
présidente on poursuit madame yououfa le
1093 je souhaitais
défendre cet
amendement en fait c'est pas grave moi
je suis insoumis aux insoumis donc comme
ça ça se passa très bien le 10
madame
Youssoufa madame
Youssoufa attention parce que ceux qui
cré des troubles dans l'Assemblée
nationale risque des sanctions je vous
le rappelle madame Youfa le
1093 cet amendement propose de lever
certaines protections absolu ou relativ
concernant les mesures d'explulion pour
les étrangers condamnés en première
instance pour des faits de violence
sexuelle de viol
je défends de la même
manière l'amendement suivant que je
dépose qui est un amendement de repli
qui propose de lever certaines
protections absolu ou relativ concernant
les mesures d'expulsion pour les
étrangers condamnés définitivement pour
des faits de violence de viol ou
d'agression sexuelle cet amendement vise
la levée des protections lors de la
condamnation définitive je vous
remercie
mais monsieur bernalicis vous arrêtez de
vous vous arrêtez de vous comporter
comme un gamin turbulent lors de la lors
de la proposition de résolution
européenne sur le droit de la mer nous
avons siégé en même temps que la
discussion générale sur la proposition
de résolution européenne ça nous a posé
aucun problème aucun problème la fois
dernière quand c'est les textes des
autres c'est la commission des lois qui
était saisie au fond de cette PPR ça
vous a posé aucun problème indign à
géométrie variable ça suffit vous n'avez
pas raison donc vous arrêtez votre
cinéma monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
un amendement
1683 sur l'amendement 1093 monsieur le
Président
adidéfavorable en effet les infractions
visées sont plus larges que celles qui
ont été strictement présenté comme étant
les les agressions sexuelles ou les
assess ça vise notamment les appels
téléphoniques malveillants ou les
menaces
ce titre cela nous paraî aller trop loin
en matière de levé de protection avis
déforable monsieur le ministre oui je
veux dire à Madame yououfa que c'est la
même esprit que la réflexion qu'on a
fait à Madame genev on peut toujours
discuter du quantum moi je propose que
l'on travaille pour la séance soit sur
la question du quantum soit sur la
question du quantum de 5 ans rjoutant
les thèmes des délits qui peut-être peut
embarquer comme vous l'avez évoqué
l'expulsion des
donc comme pour madame jeunevard je
renvoie le débat en séance pour ajouter
les choses mais comme je trouve que nos
débats sont extrêmement clairs j'espère
que vous m'avz parfaitement compris
voilà et sinon j'espère que ceux qui
nous écoutent voient ce qui se passe
actuellement Monsieur Lucas merci merci
monsieur le
Président je voudrais
dire je voudrais dire extrêmement
calmement mais monsieur le mais avec
beaucoup de gravité que nous n'avons
monsieur le Président dans notre
fonctionnement parlementaire qu'une
journée d'initiative parlementaire
laissé à chaque groupe de l'opposition
c'est peut-être trop pour certains mais
c'est un droit qui est essentiel à la
pluralité démocratique et qui je crois
est reconnu ici par toutes et par tous
il y a un texte extrêmement important
mais même s'il ne n'était pas d'ailleurs
ça ne changerait rien à l'initiative
d'un certain nombre de nos collègues à
l'initiative d'un groupe parlementaire
qui est un texte qui concerne
directement tous les commissaires de
cette commission qui ont travaillé
dessus et mais les les déclarations
générales monsieur le Président Mayard
elles éclairent le débat sur le texte il
n'y a pas que les vote qui compte il y a
la discussion la démocratie ce n'est pas
que le vote la démocratie c'est aussi la
discussion monsieur le Président dans un
souci d'apaisement y compris pour
reprendre nos travaux qui d'ailleurs
avancai très bien cet après-midi je vous
demande au nom de mon groupe que nous
puissions lever la séance de la
Commission pour rejooindre l'examen de
ce texte en séance et ainsi faire notre
travail de législateur dans de bonnes
conditions et nous serons à vos côté
nous serons à vos côtés dans les
réclamations que vous portez auprès de
la Conférence des Présidents sur la
surcharge de travail de cette commission
et sur les façons dramatique dans
lesquels on permet au législateurs de
faire la loi dans notre pays bien
j'aurais bien que vous soyez à mes côtés
quand j'ai demandé cela il y a 2
semaines ça n'a pas été le cas
malheureusement du reste je redis que
quand c'était la PPRE déposée par le
monsieur Dumont qu'on a siégé en séance
y compris sur les amendements ça vous a
posé aucun problème je suspendrai donc
pour les amendements tout à l'heure à
21h30 en attendant nous termin notre
session le 1093 qui vote pour qui vote
contre qui vote contre
est rejeté le le 1100 qui vote pour qui
vote contre rejeté également et le 1683
du rapporteur qui vote pour qui vote
contre il est adopté alors il fait
tomber les l'amendement je crois 100 de
Madame buffet il fait tomber le 601 le
1074 le 825 le
473 le 389 le 807 le 417 et le
517 monsieur monsieur neigelen si vous
arrivez à défendre vre amendement
allez-y allez monsieur neigelen allez-y
le
[Musique]
672 oh ça
suffit monsieur
zv
monsieur monsieur rassz-vous et défendez
amendementsieur vous n'avez aucune
autorité ici c'est pas vous qui
décidez monsieur prenez un autre endroit
pour défendre votre
amendement
donc en fait monsieur le
Président donc en fait c'est un
amendement qui visait à lever un
obstacle à l'expulsion de certains
étrangers présentant une menace grave
pour l'ordre public en supprimant une
des catégories de protection prévu à
l'article 631
1.3 du cza en fait cet amendement permet
d'aller plus loin pour cette catégorie
spécifique
ex pourle men grave à l'ordre public
dans le cas de l'étranger résidant
habituellement en franceuis C 13
ans monsieur le
rapporteur avis défavorable à cet
amendement 672 en effet retirer la
protection don bénéfici les mineurs
Résid en France depuis l'âge de 13 ans
excessif etré un déséquilibre dans
l'article
monsieur Lom c'est pour agir au fond
[Musique]
j'imaginesur
présidentés je
croiseffectivementous députés du
rassemblement national qui se mettent à
fumer en plein milieu de la séance ce
qui me semble
être relatif au fait que il sont un
petit peu en train de de craquer pour
certains d'entre eux maintenant si nous
voulons que nous puissions tenir nos
débats sereinement je crois qu'il serait
bon que nous suspendions et si nous ne
le faisons pas je seraiis au regret de
vous dire que nous déposerons des
scrutins public non seulement sur les
amendements de la fin de cette soirée
mais que nous ne voyons aucun problème
pour ce qui nous concerne à en déposer
sur l'ensemble des amendements qui
viendront ensuite je préfère vous le
dire
maintenant bien Monsieur Madame
Youfa je tiens à soutenir le président
nagelen qui a essayé de défendre son
amendement malbr le bruit le chaos et
les menaces donc je vais répéter que son
amendement vise à lever un obstacle à
l'expulsion de certains étrangers
présentant une menace grave pour l'ordre
public en supprimant une desé de
protection et nous le répéterons je
tiendrai le micro pendant encore 40
secondes et vous vous pouvez continuer à
vciféré je continu je continuerai pour
le groupe lot le travail qui est le
nôtre c'est-à-dire de débattre votre
mise en scène ne servira à rien je vous
invite à venir ici faire ce que vous
avez fait face au président nageline de
venir vous vous interposer physiquement
en haussant la voix continuez continuez
venez enleverz votre manteau et venez
ici menacer une femme continuez allez-y
allez-y j'ai hâte de voir ça vos menaces
sont
h vous donnez un spectacle lamentable de
la démocratie lamentable vous mettez en
scène votre
nullité cet amendement va plus loin pour
cette catégorie spécifique en permettant
d'expulser par simple menace
grave oui merci monsieur le
Président les menaces envers madame sont
pas acceptbl premièrement
deuxièmement est-ce que deuxièmement
est-ce que les révolutionnaires en
carton que vous êtes peuvent se taire
chacun ira porter ce sujet auprès du
Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale et la
Conférence des Présidents fera ce
qu'elle a à faire mais en attendant
arrêtez de vous comporter comme vous le
faites on n'est pas dans un cirque et on
n pas dans vos
manifestations alors l'amendement de
Monsieur 72 qui vote
pour qui vote contre il est
rejeté le alors attendez parce que j'ai
l'amendement 287 qui n'est pas
défendu et j'ai l'amendement ils sont
pas défendus les amendements que vous
sur lequels vous avez mis les scrutin
public je suis désolé le 769 est
tombé le 1667 était tombé
également 289
1077 qui est tombé le
290 était tombé
aussi et donc le 1077 monsieur
valallot alors monsieur le ministre vous
voulez parler non mais je pense qu'il
faudra qu'on reparle le 7 amendement
672 oui mais monsieur monsieur Bern j'ai
été depuis que je suis ministre je suis
présent toute la commission je vous ai
pas beaucoup vue la commission des lois
je suis pas de venir il me semble que
c'est votre travail que de le faire
maintenant vous avez manifestement envie
de pas étudier le texte c'est votre
problèmeêtes pas obligé de menacer vous
n'êtes pas obligé de menacer vous n'êtes
pas obligé de menacer une parlementaire
comme vous l'avez fait vous n'êtes pas
obligé de parler de mon
Agana personnellement j' crié sur
personne moi je vous ai expliqué que je
suis présent samedi dimanche lundi à
Noël tant que vous voulez je constate
que alors que rien m'y oblige je suis
présent toutes les séances c'était pas
votre cas donc pour les leçons de
maintien pour les leçons de maintien
vous les garderez c'est pas grave mais
non mais monsieur Bern tout le monde n'a
pas tout le monde n'a pas le bonheur de
vous avoir comme voisin de
circonscription dans le Nord si ceux qui
étaient élus dans le Nord connaissaient
vos habitudes il n serit pas touché je
veux simplement dire à Monsieur neigelen
et à Madame youssoufin qui a cependant
mais moi je ne monsieur monsieur
bernalicis monsieur bernalicis monsieur
bernalicis monsieur
bernalicis monsieur ber je ne me mêle
pas de votre relation avec la commission
vous m'avez attaqué nommément tout à
l'heure permettez-moi que je vous
réponde en vous disant que mon agenda
est à votre totale disposition Parlement
en vous démontrant monsieur Lucas la
souigné c'est moi je ne préside pas la
Commission et je ne fais pas partie du
CIRC que vous menez donc personnellement
je suis à votre disposition je l'ai
montré depuis le début je suis là samedi
dimanche et pour les jours fériers et
j'ai essayé de vous démontrer que
j'étais plus présent dans votre
commission que vous-même donc monsieur
bernalicis reprenons quelques instants
de de
calme je voudrais simplement dire à
Madame yououfa et à Monsieur nagen sur
l'amendement 672 que si je peux
comprendre leur proposition qui vient
manifestement d'être adopté si j'ai bien
compris le sens des votes mais j'avoue
que c'était un peu confus il faud qu'on
y revienne dans l'hémicycle parce que on
a un gros sujet juridique s'il a pas été
adopté c'est une très bonne chose mais
j'ai même pas compris le résultat du
vote ce qui commence à poser un problème
quand
même non j'ai pas compris parce que
monsieur bernalissis vous êtes vous vous
comportez pas comme un parlementaire de
la nation mais c'est pas le même
problème chacun le constate chacun le
constate non mais non mais
Hugo n'est manifestement pas prêt pour
Bovo là donc il va falloir va falloir
prendre un
petit va falloir un petit peu murir va
falloir un petit peu murir bon
éventuellement prêt pour une assemblée
générale d'étudiants mais mais pas pour
le ministère de l'intérieur mais onah
oui en tout cas il y a au moins encore 4
ans à attendre au moins facilement
ouais donc simplement dire que cet
amendement je sais pas s'il été adopté
monsieur le Président bon bah s'il a pas
été adopté on aura l'occasion de
reparler dans l'hémicle
alors le 290 est tombé parce que son son
auteur n'est pas présent le 1077
monsieur Valo
1077 les conditions sont pas réunies un
examen serin défendu les conditions ne
sont pas réuni pour un examen sin je
suis désolé mais c'est pas moi qui qui
suis
responsable le 1638 le 821 madame Martin
allez-y et vous le mettez au vote il a
été il est défendu monsieur Vall bien
sûr défendu alors
Monsieur avis avis défavorable je mets
au voix qui vote pour je voulais
intervenir ah pardon monsieur de la
porte de monsieur le Président il est
19h59 ça fait un quart d'heure qu'on
narrive pas à s'entendre oui président
il y a des explications à cela parce que
les demandes de nos collègues sont de
pouvoir aller en séance desbex la
Commission des LO elles sont audibles le
problème monsieur le président Président
c'est que on aurait pu anticiper ce
débat moi ça fait un quart d'heure que
je ne comprends rien à ce qui se passe
et je peux pas mener mon travail de
parlementaire de manière sereine alors
qu'on est en train de débattre de choses
importantes là il s'agit d'un amendement
qui est suggéré par l'unsf pour
réintroduire des mesures d'expulsion et
il y a des enfants derrière tout ça il y
a des débat important c'est c'est
vraiment insupportable on a tous la tête
je sais pas s'il y avait un compteur de
décibel mais on a atteint un niveau je
trouve de débat parlementaire qui est
insupportable il est 20h monsieur le
Président je vous demande de suspendre
cette
commission n est pas parce que d'abord
on va faire voter l'amendement 1077 et
ensuite moi j'ai constaté quand même que
ça faisait 40 minutes que la discussion
générale avait commencé en séance dans
le plus grand indifférence la plus
grande indifférence de la France
insoumise au bout de 40 minutes
c'està-dire à 19h40 monsieur bernalicis
est venu mettre un bazar incroyable en
commission ce que je proposeraiis de
faire c'est de saisir la présidente de
l'Assemblée sur les troubles qu'il a
causé gravement à la commission des lois
et pour lequel je demanderai des
sanctions voilà des sanctions très
clairement donc maintenant il est 20h on
va voter le 1077
qui a reçu un avis défavorable de la
part du rapporteur qui vote pour qui
vote contre il est rejeté et donc
maintenant il est 20h nous pouvons
suspendre notre commission merci on se
retrouve demain à 9h puisque tout à
l'heure nous avons la séance comme vous
le savez
naturellement